they've got a bunch of guys banged up
right now bryce harper on the il
gregorius roman quinn is out for the
year
this one shot out to right center robles
over and a nice lunging catch
victor robles drops it after he had
controls the grab
and they will give him the out there
great play by the national center
fielder ranging way
to his left look how far he runs for
this baseball this ball is
in the gap 100 and he runs it down
and definitely there's no question that
he caught it he just dropped it on the
transfer there
but an amazing play and i can't wait to
see the statcast and you see max is
fired up
knowing his center fielder has his back
june 10th the park will be totally open
full capacity lead off walk for trey
turner here in the fourth inning
nationals have their first base runner
he's been banged up a bit this season so
he's not been as good as he was in
previous years but
he's been known for his pop time he gets
rid of the ball very quickly very strong
arm this season though maybe to your
point with the injuries has only caught
two runners attempting to steal
fastball to the left side bone will go
the long way
and get harrison at first turner moves
into scoring position with one out
best case scenario there moving trey
over so here's josh bell now with trey
turner still out there at second base
and
two away now antares you can see them
there at the bottom left of your screen
he is staying right in trey's left hip
pocket
pops this one to the left side will it
get down here comes mccutchen a sliding
attempt is no good trey turner will come
in
josh bell hustling the second and a
little bloop double the left field has
given the nationals a one-nothing lead
right off the knuckles here you can see
this ball beat him right off the label
it's a big strong dude and mccutcheon is
playing
fairly deep this ball
clearly drops in but the best part about
this
josh bell got on his horse and got to
second base
so now the nationals have another runner
in scoring position
segura hits it sharply through the home
left side a base hit
police have their second hit and for the
second straight inning they get the lead
off hitter aboard
here's reece
what are the warning track is last time
segura goes pitch is taken for strike
throw to second is high
and he is safe at second base what the
heck is josh harrison doing
a great jump and a great pitch to go on
a breaking ball by scherzer and
yeah his right leg kicked up in the air
and hit josh
right in the right in the face
now that's something i've never seen
i'll tell you what you're lucky too with
sigour he didn't hurt his thumb
or even his the way he went in too john
yeah his head look at this
he stops himself from getting his
hitting his jaw on the turf
that one's cold past the diving turner
into left center field sigour is going
to score
jt ties it up it's a one-one game
after a strikeout to keep from keeps the
girl from advancing to third base less
than two outs jt
just hammers one up the middle for a
base hit
segura scores easily and now
keep your eye on jt
fell the rbi double back in the fourth
starlin castro a leadoff single in the
fifth
and that's about it for the nats off
zach wheeler
a little trigger on that one this ball
is crushed to left field
juan soto has put the nationals on top
in the sixth
[Applause]
absolutely crush this ball standing dead
into the eyes of zach wheeler
i mean this ball is destroyed he stared
at him a little bit run into first he
stared at him after he touched home
plate
i don't know if there was something that
happened in an earlier at-bat but juan
soto is fired up and so are his
teammates yeah i love it
so then that's got one in the top of the
fourth and the phillies quickly answered
in the bottom half we'll see if max can
post to zero here in the sixth the 2-2
flipped out to right field soto coming
in makes a nice slide and catch
and he can do it on both sides of the
ball dan
oh yeah both in the infield and the
outfield good job by juan good
break nice smooth sliding catch
i feel like he just loves staring into
the phillies dugout or at the
philly opposing pitcher
wheeler though a struck out seven yeah
the o2
swag and a miss 96 make it eight
eight strikeouts tonight for zach
wheeler
time to get this man some runs
see what max has for alec baume in this
kill count
fastball got him atop the zone
96 past him eighth strikeout for matt
scherzer
max blown away the young phillies
right-hander
reaching back for a little bit more
no two-strike adjustment equals a punch
out
popped up right side
josh bell max scherzer's out of a jam in
the seventh inning
then ads will take a 2-1 lead to the
eighth in philadelphia
swinging a miss max pulls out the change
up
ninth strikeout of the game
well max do a couple change up to matt
joyce here in this at-bat and this is
the last one to get him for the
strikeout excellent pitch
do they go fastball in do they go slider
away
slider down below the zone and avila has
jankowski caught between second and
third
he runs right at him still has the ball
and that's a huge out for the nationals
and a huge base running miscue
by the pinch runner great heads-up play
by alex avila
and joe girardi is going to be answering
questions about this one for the rest of
the evening from the phillies
making sure he commits one way or the
other
got him hung up there popped up alertly
and go instead of giving the ball up
make sure you
make sure the base runner goes towards
one way
second base or third base who's such a
good job by alex and that's a long run
for him to get the out
the one-two
slider popped into shallow center
victor robles says he has it and he does
the nationals have taken the first game
of this three-game series with the
phillies
wat soto is fired up
and they have won this ball game 2-1